IS THE FACT THAT
WE'RE PROBABLY GONNA
HAVE WORK OFF TOMORROW.
- WHOA, I DIDN'T
EVEN THINK OF THAT.
- YES, OF COURSE WE ARE!
- THAT'S AWESOME.
- OF COURSE WE ARE,
IT'S A DEATH DAY.
IT'S LIKE A SNOW DAY,
BUT IT'S A DEATH DAY.
- AND CHECK THIS OUT.
I GOT A SWEDISH PEN PAL IN TOWN.
SHE'S IN VEGAS RIGHT NOW.
WANTS TO COME TO HOLLYWOOD,
WHICH IS WHERE
I TOLD HER WE LIVE.
- WE DON'T.
- SMART, VERY SMART.
- I KNOW.
I CAN'T SAY RANCHO CUCAMONGA.
THEY DON'T KNOW WHAT THAT IS.
THEY'RE FROM SWEDEN!
THEY'RE NOT GONNA KNOW.
- YEAH,
SWEDES DON'T KNOW ANYTHING.
- YEAH, YOU GOTTA
SAY HOLLYWOOD.
- HEY, DERS, IS THIS THE SAME
CHICK THAT YOU TOLD US ABOUT
WHERE YOU SQUEEZED HER BOOB
THROUGH HER SLEEVE
WHILE WATCHING GLADIATOR
IN YOUR FRIEND'S BASEMENT?
- OH, YEAH.
- YEAH.
AND IT WAS A LONG SLEEVE SHIRT,
SO WHERE'S MY DAP AT?
- DUDE, I NEED
SOME SLEEVE BOOB MYSELF.
I'M TAKING
THE OTHER CHICK, TOO,
AND I APOLOGIZE IN ADVANCE
FOR MARRYING HER.
WHOO, YES.
- NICE. QUICK ON THE DRAW.
DAP ON THE DIBSTER MAN.
- I DON'T KNOW ABOUT DAP,
ACTUALLY.
- BUT I'M GONNA HAVE TO SAY NO,
BECAUSE THERE'S ONLY ONE PURE
FAIR WAY TO DECIDE WHO'S GONNA
BE MY BRO-PILOT ON THIS ONE.
- 87. 87!
- 87?
- I'M MAXED OUT. 87.
- OKAY. OKAY, THAT'S--THAT'S
A PRETTY HIGH BAR, BLAZER.
SO THAT MEANS YOU ONLY HAVE
TO PUT ON...
NONE,
BECAUSE I'M CHOOSING YOU.
- NO. NO!
- YOU--YOU SERIOUS?
- YEAH, I'M SERIOUS, DUDE.
YOU LOOK LIKE A PROFESSIONAL
SKATING CELEBRITY.
THE SWEDISH CHICKS
WILL DIG THAT.
- YEAH, MAN!
PRO SKATER, I CAN DO THAT.
NO PROBLEM.
BLAKER HAS A DEATH WISH.
- NO, NO, NO.
ADAM HAS A DEATH WISH.
- WELL, YOU SHOULD HAVE THOUGHT
ABOUT THAT WHEN YOU WERE PUTTING
SPERMICIDE
ON MY FRENCH CRULLER.
O'DERS RULES!
BLAKE, LET'S DAP OUT OF HERE.
- NO!
OH!